si vous habitez la provence côte d'azur
le couloir rhodanien soyez prudents ce
soir et demain il pleuvra encore maryse
burgot les mêmes images que la semaine
dernière
ou presque mais cette fois l'orage a
surtout frappé la côte d'azur
un véritable déluge vers minuit sur
antibes et dans les rues de cannes
les voitures en sont encore tout
retourné et elles ne sont pas les celle
ci doit commencer à rentrer de ce côté
aussi beaucoup de dégâts matériels aussi
dans la région rhône alpes on avait bien
construit un mur d'un mètre cinquante
pour contenir les eaux de l'yzeron peine
perdue une nouvelle fois l'affluent du
rhône a débordé ils ont l'habitude les
habitants d'oullins et de sainte foy
c'est déjà arrivé en 84 87 et 89
toute la journée le niveau des rivières
à d'ailleurs continué à monter en isère
cet après midi à beaurepaire
une centaine de personnes ont dû évacuer
leurs maisons dans le nord du
département
on ne compte plus les routes coupées les
caves inondées